Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to the very last Rest Is History of 2022. And Dominic, we are still in Bury Brothers, aren't we? We are. So in the previous episode, we came to Bury Brothers in the heart of London's West End, St James, to record an episode on the history of booze with Henry Jeffreys, which was great and he's now gone off to do whatever one three days ago tom yeah that's the truth we've been camped out here yeah in the cellar days so here we are and dominic at the beginning
感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听 2022 年最后一期《历史其余部分》。多米尼克，我们现在还在贝瑞兄弟（Bury Brothers）酒商，对吧？是的。所以在上一集里，我们来到了位于伦敦西区核心地带圣詹姆斯的贝瑞兄弟，和亨利·杰弗里斯（Henry Jeffreys）一起录制了一集关于酒的历史的节目，非常精彩。现在他已经去忙别的了，不管是什么……三天前，汤姆。是的，千真万确。我们一直在这里露营，就在酒窖里。好几天了，所以我们在这儿。多米尼克，在今年
of the year we did an episode on 1922 to mark the centenary of it and we said that this was a truly historic year a year when perhaps modernity was born. And so the obvious question is, in 100 years time, when we're still doing this podcast, will we look back and see 2022 as being of a similarly historic order? I mean, I guess the one obvious,
初，我们做了一期关于 1922 年的节目来纪念它的百年诞辰，当时我们说这确实是一个具有历史意义的年份，也许现代性正是在那一年诞生的。那么显而易见的问题是，在 100 年后，当我们依然在做这个播客时，我们会回过头来，把 2022 年也看作是具有同等历史重要性的一年吗？我想，人们在历史书中研究的一个显而易见、
huge historic thing that people will be studying in history books is Russia's invasion of Ukraine. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. Well, if you look back to that 1922 podcast we did i'm trying to think of all the different things we covered because we covered british politics we covered international affairs didn't we culture so it was um the wasteland yeah ulysses and i think that is the thing that makes 1922 specific so actually yeah the the book on 1922 which is it kevin jackson's book i think it
极其重大的历史事件就是俄罗斯对乌克兰的侵入。是的，我想这绝对没错。如果你回看我们做的那期 1922 年的播客——我在努力回想我们涵盖的所有不同主题，因为我们谈到了英国政治、国际事务，还有文化，对吧？所以有……《荒原》（The Wasteland），还有《尤利西斯》（Ulysses）。我认为正是这一点赋予了 1922 年其特殊性。所以实际上，关于 1922 年的那本书——是凯文·杰克逊（Kevin Jackson）的书吧，我想
is it largely focuses actually on the on modernism and 1922 as a cultural sort of hinge point and i suppose the problem with that is that the whole thing about modernism is that it's very very obscure and only very few people know that it's going on so if there's an analogous cultural experiment i mean we won't have heard of it we're not at the avant-garde tom i think that's that we're not also i think um i'm sure we talked about this in in that podcast there was a sense that you know the age of proust and joyce and picasso and stravinsky this was the kind of the last age of the great man as artist and that really has kind of faded now hasn't it yes i mean 2022 has been a year of course of talk of cancellation of toppling people from their pedestals like the
它其实主要聚焦于现代主义，以及作为一种文化转折点的 1922 年。我想这里的问题在于，关于现代主义的全部关键点在于它是极其晦涩难懂的，只有极少数人知道它正在发生。因此，如果存在某种类似的文化实验——我的意思是，我们不会听说过它，我们并不在前卫的浪潮之中，汤姆，我想就是这样——我们不是。而且我认为，嗯，我确信我们在那期播客中讨论过这一点，当时有一种感觉，你知道，普鲁斯特（Proust）、乔伊斯（Joyce）、毕加索（Picasso）和斯特拉文斯基（Stravinsky）的时代，这是作为艺术家的“伟大人物”的最后一个时代，而这种感觉现在确实已经消退了，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，2022 年当然也是一个充斥着取消文化（cancellation）、将人们从神坛上拉下来的年份，就像
last few years so that kind of runs counter to the very great man view of artistic creation that you so you have in 1922 where it's about the genius of t.s elliott or james joyce as you say but i think even at the time there was a sense wasn there, in the early 20s that a lot of social, cultural, political assumptions had fractured in the aftermath of the First World War, and that Britain, Europe, and the world were trying to adjust to a new age. I don't think we quite have that sense, do we? No, not at all. Because the modernists were, you know, these fragments of I shored against my ruin, Elliot, as Elliot puts it, in the wasteland. It's the sense that the civilization has shattered and all you can do really is kind of make collages out of the shattered pieces. But it is still the great man who is doing that, Picasso, Joyce, whoever.
过去几年一样。所以这与你所拥有的 1922 年那种非常宏大的“伟大人物”艺术创造观是背道而驰的，在 1922 年，一切都关乎 T·S·艾略特（T.S. Eliot）或詹姆斯·乔伊斯（正如你所说）的天才。但我认为，即使在当时，在 20 年代早期，人们也有一种感觉，即在第一次世界大战之后，许多社会、文化和政治假设都已经破裂，英国、欧洲乃至世界都在努力适应一个新时代。我觉得我们现在没有这种感觉，对吧？不，完全没有。因为现代主义者是……你知道的，“这些残片，我已为抵御我的废墟而收集，”艾略特，正如艾略特在《荒原》中所说的那样。那种感觉是文明已经粉碎，你真正能做的只是用这些破碎的碎片拼贴出一些东西。但创造这一切的仍然是伟大的个体——毕加索、乔伊斯，无论他是谁。
But no one would say that now. I mean, you know, there is no longer anyone who serves as the paradigmatic great novelist, great painter, great composer, or even, you know, kind of great pop star, great rock star. Yeah. Partly because of the multiplication of outlets, I suppose. I'm sure that's it. Because of the fragmentation of culture. And also globalisation, perhaps. Globalisation, yeah.
但现在没有人会这么说了。我的意思是，你知道，不再有任何人充当范式意义上的伟大作家、伟大画家、伟大作曲家，甚至，你知道的，那种伟大的流行歌星、伟大摇滚巨星。是的。部分原因大概是因为传播渠道的增多。我确信就是这样。因为文化的碎片化。还有全球化，也许吧。全球化，是的。
Agreed. Agreed. and also globalization perhaps yeah agreed agreed but to go back to your what you said at the beginning um when people write about this year in 21 22 they will undoubtedly think of the events of late february when russia launched that invasion of ukraine i think that's there's a sense now we did podcast didn't we in the immediate aftermath of that about ukrainian history russian history but there's a real sense i think in which i mean we did a podcast quite early on in the whole course of the rest of history about the 1990s and i've been thinking a lot about the 90s this year and how many of the things that have as it were gone wrong how many of them started in the 90s so
完全同意。完全同意。还有全球化，也许吧。是的，同意，同意。但回到你刚才在开头时说的话，当人们在 2122 年书写今年时，他们无疑会想到二月底俄罗斯对乌克兰发动那场入侵时的情景。我认为那种感觉现在依然存在——我们在那之后不久就做了一期播客，不是吗？关于乌克兰历史、俄罗斯历史。但我觉得有一种真正的感觉，我的意思是，我们在《历史其余部分》整个节目的早期，曾做过一期关于 20 世纪 90 年代的播客，今年我一直在思考 90 年代，以及有多少事情——可以说是出了差错——它们其实都是从 90 年代开始的。所以
russia taking this turn into this sort of weimar Germany sort of abyss, if you like. Reality TV? Right, the career of Matt Hancock. No, but I think when people write about this year, they will see this as the moment when the immediate post-Cold War era ended. Don't you think? Yeah. More so, actually, I would would say now this might be controversial than september the 11th because september the 11th now feels like of course it's a massive moment
俄罗斯转向了这种类似魏玛德国式的深渊，如果你愿意这么说的话。真人秀？没错，马特·汉考克（Matt Hancock）的职业生涯。不，但我觉得当人们在书写今年时，他们会把这视为冷战后时代正式结束的时刻。你不这么觉得吗？是的。甚至，实际上我会说——这可能会引起争议——相比于 9th of September（9月11日），因为现在 9·11 感觉像是一个巨大的时刻，当然它在
in american history but in world history i wonder whether it's quite as significant now as we thought it was 20 years ago you might say it's too early to tell you might say that because because the 9-11 people thought was was a decisive world moment because it was felt as presaging clash of civilizations yeah and it was all about tensions between the west and islam and that sense i think has definitely faded but it's it's not impossible to imagine you know cycles of terrorist attacks or something that might regenerate that and i guess the kind of you know the the sense of strain hasn't faded. It hasn't gone away.
美国历史上是个大事件，但在世界历史上，我怀疑它是否还像我们 20 年前想象的那样具有重大意义。你可能会说现在下结论还为时过早，你可能会说，因为人们曾认为 9·11 是一个决定性的世界时刻，因为它被视为文明冲突的前兆，是的，这全关于西方与伊斯兰世界之间的紧张关系。这种感觉现在绝对已经消退了，但并非不可想象，你知道，恐怖袭击的周期或其他什么可能会让这种感觉再次燃起。我想那种紧张感并没有消退，它并没有消失。
No. In terms of pressures on the frontiers of Europe. Tom, there's people outside trying to shut you down. Force their way in. Yeah. So, I mean, I would say that, you know, in 2005 or was it 2015 when there was the migration crisis? Yeah, 2015 or so.
没有。就欧洲边境所承受的压力而言。汤姆，外面有人正试图让你闭嘴呢。试图强行闯入。是的。所以，我的意思是，我会说，在 2005 年，还是 2015 年发生了移民危机的时候？是的，2015 年左右。
So I would say back then, if you'd done a kind of end of the year, you'd say these are seismic issues. But they faded. They seem to have less saliency now, even though in Britain one of the things that has dominated the headlines is people trying to cross the Channel in small boats. So that is obviously kind of bubbling away. But I agree, it doesn't seem to have the salience that say, the threat of superpower conflict does. Because back in 2001, 9-11 seemed so shocking, because it interrupted what people had assumed was an era of kind of constant peace, where the very idea of, you know, countries going to war was kind of over, or at least, you know, countries in the west but i think the ukrainian war also feels that it has this resonance because we're living in a period where the assumptions of western liberal democracy are embattled anyway so post-financial crisis post i mean you mentioned the migration crisis brexit the rise of china all these different things mean that the sense of unity and kind of complacency i guess that you would associate with western democracy certainly in the 1990s that has really completely fractured
所以我想说，回到那时，如果你做过某种年终总结，你会说这些都是震动全局的问题。但它们已经消退了。现在它们似乎没有那么突出了，尽管在英国，占据头条新闻的事情之一仍然是人们试图乘小船横渡英吉利海峡。所以这显然还在隐隐发酵。但我同意，它似乎不像超级大国冲突的威胁那样具有现实针对性。因为早在 2001 年，9·11 显得如此令人震惊，是因为它打破了人们原本以为的那个持续和平的时代，在那个时代，国家之间走向战争的想法似乎已经结束了，或者至少，你知道的，西方国家是这样的。但我觉得乌克兰战争也让人觉得它具有这种共鸣，因为我们生活在一个西方自由民主制度的基本假设无论如何都受到攻击的时期。所以经历了金融危机、经历了——我的意思是，你提到了移民危机、英国脱欧、中国的崛起，所有这些不同的事件意味着，你会在 20 世纪 90 年代将之与西方民主国家联系在一起的那种团结感和某种自满情绪，确实已经彻底破裂了。
and so the ukrainian war is it and sorry really miss it well i love being complacent but don't you think now that i i definitely think now that after what happened in february and then the the the slaughter that has followed you know i look back on what on the events of the 1990s and think it was all just a complete illusion i mean i'm sounding a little bit like adam curtis here but yeah but i mean yeah let's have a jump cut to people throwing a ball about in a 1950s american swimming pool yes and oddly oddly jarring music. But so Adam Curtis, for those people who don't know, is this brilliantly talented BBC filmmaker who creates these documentaries that are kind of,
所以乌克兰战争就是——抱歉，真的错过了。哦，我喜欢保持自满，但你不觉得现在——我绝对觉得现在，在 2月份发生的事情以及随之而来的大屠杀之后，你知道，我回想起 20 世纪 90 年代的种种事件，觉得那一切都只是个彻底的幻觉。我的意思是，我听起来有点像亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis），但是——是的，但我的意思是，让我们来个跳切（jump cut），切到 1950 年代美国游泳池里人们在抛球的画面，是的，伴随着一种奇怪的、刺耳的音乐。但话说回来，亚当·柯蒂斯，对于那些不了解的人来说，是一位才华横溢的 BBC 纪录片导演，他制作的这些纪录片，可以说是
they're a combination of a collage and a conspiracy theory, and I don't mean that too harshly. And he had a brilliant new series on Russia, didn't he, on the post-Soviet history of Russia, entirely made up of footage that he sourced. So no commentary or anything. And Dominic, weren't you watching one of those episodes on a train, on a laptop?
拼贴画与阴谋论的结合体，我这话并没有贬低的意思。他有一部关于俄罗斯的精彩新系列纪录片，不是吗？关于俄罗斯后苏联时期的历史，完全由他搜集的素材剪辑而成。没有任何解说词之类的东西。多米尼克，你当时是不是正坐在火车上用笔记本电脑看其中一集？
Well, I think our club members will have heard this anecdote already. So Tom and I, we did two episodes, didn't we, about the history of treason at the National Archives. And on my way down to the National Archives on the train, I was watching, I can't remember, it was episode three, episode four of that series. And on my laptop, because I was so addicted to it, it's such an immersive series, it plunges you into that
我想我们的俱乐部成员应该已经听过这个轶事了。所以汤姆和我，我们做了两集关于国家档案馆叛国罪历史的节目，对吧？在我坐火车前往国家档案馆的路上，我正在看——我不记得了，是那一系列的第三集还是第四集。在我的笔记本电脑上，因为我太入迷了，这是一个极其沉浸式的系列，它把你带入了那个
very Weimar Republic world of mid-1990s Russia, in which the economy had completely collapsed, living standards had collapsed and so on, enormous political turmoil. So I was watching this on my laptop with my headphones, very crowded train and um it suddenly the the sort of there's no voiceover so they use captions the caption on the screen said people turn to unusual ways to make money and i thought oh no what's coming now
充满魏玛共和国色彩的 95 年代中期俄罗斯世界，那里的经济已经彻底崩溃，生活水平崩塌等等，政治动荡极其剧烈。所以我戴着耳机在笔记本电脑上看着这个，火车上人非常挤。然后突然间……它没有旁白，所以他们用的是字幕，屏幕上的字幕写着：“人们开始转向不寻常的方式来赚钱。”我心想：“哦不，接下来要播什么了？”
and then the camera the picture cut to a couple very very explicitly having sex in front of some cameras on their bed sort of this amateur couple and i thought oh god it'll just be for a moment and then over the life i crashed but no the scene went on and on i was sitting next to this young woman who's very smartly dressed kind of she was ostentatiously like looking at her work for the day. And I thought, oh, I can't bet. This is so excruciating. So I tried to sort of fast forward to the next scene or something on the BBC iPlayer, which I have to say is a very clumsy bit of online technology.
然后镜头、画面切到了一对男女，非常、非常露骨地在他们的床上、在一些镜头前做爱，有点像那种业余情侣。我心想：“天哪，这应该只持续一会儿吧。”接着我的播放器就崩溃了。但并没有，那个场景一直在继续。我正坐在一个年轻女性旁边，她穿着非常时髦，那种……她还在摆出一副很专注的样子看着当天的工作。我心想：“天哪，我不能这样。这太折磨人了。”所以我试图在 BBC iPlayer 上快进到下一个场景或其他什么，我必须说，那是一个操作非常笨拙的在线技术。
Because as soon as I moved the thing on, the picture just froze. And I had this sort of circle on the screen going around and around the picture froze you just hurled it out of the window very very unfortunate close up pull the emergency cord and and i could feel my face absolutely burning and i and i so i sort of even though i had my headphones on i sort of very very artificially and inauthentically said, oh, for God's sake, or something. And then closed the laptop in a great sort of, in a great bit of a lava, I think it's fair to say. Anyway, so obviously for that reason,
因为我一把进度条往前拉，画面就直接卡住了。我的屏幕上出现了一个圆圈在不停地转啊转，画面彻底卡死。你简直想把它直接扔出窗外。非常、非常不幸的特大特写，拉下了紧急制动绳。我能感觉到我的脸绝对是在烧红，于是我——尽管我戴着耳机，我还是非常生硬、非常不自然地脱口而出：“哦，看在上帝的份上，”或者类似的话。然后啪地一声合上了笔记本电脑，可以说是闹出了好大一出动静。总之，显而易见，正是因为这个原因——
for that reason, Russia has been much on my mind. Well, it's obviously, there was a real sense, I think, in 2022, for the first time, I would say certainly since September the 11th, since 2001 of an existential struggle don't you think I mean there was a real a feeling that a lot of people found a cause they found it a heroic figure in Vladimir Zelensky of a kind that really in the western world we haven't really put anyone on a pedestal people have got slightly bored with it in the west oh yes definitely. And slightly resentful of...
正因如此，俄罗斯一直让我魂牵梦萦。好吧，显然，在 2022 年有一种真实的感觉，我认为，自 2001 年 9·11 以来绝对是第一次，有一种面临生死存亡斗争的感觉，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，有一种真实的感受，许多人找到了一种信仰，他们在弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基（Vladimir Zelensky）身上找到了一种英雄式的人物，这种人物在西方世界里，我们其实已经很久没有把任何人奉上神坛了。西方的人们已经对这种事稍微感到厌倦了——哦，是的，绝对是的。并且开始对此感到有些怨恨……
Well, I think there have always been people who have been more bored and resentful than others. I mean, most famously in Germany. I mean, there have been German politicians who basically said explicitly to the Ukrainians in the early days of the operation, look, it would just be better if you lose right now. But what did they had? So, I mean, you're saying things are bad now, but what if Zelensky had fled
嗯，我想一直都有人比其他人更容易感到厌倦和怨恨。最著名的例子就是在德国。我的意思是，曾有德国政客在行动初期基本上明确对乌克兰人说：“听着，你们现在直接输掉其实更好。”但他们有什么？所以，我的意思是，你现在说情况很糟糕，但如果泽连斯基逃跑了，
or taken the lift that he got offered by the Americans, which he famously turned down, and the Russians had occupied Kiev? What would, where would we be now?
或者坐上了美国人提供给他的那辆他后来拒绝搭乘的电梯，而俄罗斯人占领了基辅呢？我们现在会怎样？我们在哪里？
Where would we be? That is a fascinating question, isn't it? Would the West have basically accepted the fate of grumbled imposed some sanctions but accepted the fate of complete maybe they would i don't know and what would the implications of that have been for ga politics i guess for for the security of europe and for china's um plans well i mean you you know what i'm going to say which is that um i think
我们在哪里？这是一个引人入胜的问题，不是吗？西方基本上会接受格勒姆人的命运吗？实施一些制裁，但接受彻底的命运？也许他们会，我不知道。这会对地缘政治产生什么影响？我猜对欧洲的安全以及中国的计划意味着什么？好吧，我的意思是，你知道我要说什么，那就是——我认为
there would have been very baleful implications. Of course, you could say that actually this would merely have been the continuation of a pattern because effectively nobody, I mean, there was a small bit of a fuss in sort of grand terms in 2014 when Russia took Crimea, when Russia went to war with Georgia in 2008. Again, very little fuss in the West. Even going back to, so to go back to that Adam Curtis documentary, the final episodes of it, which are unbelievably harrowing, I have to say, are about the war in Chechnya. And that was an unbelievably brutal campaign, just the complete destruction of the capital city, Grozny. And effectively, people in the West saying, well, we don't care. You know, it's an internal Russian affair.
那将带来非常灾难性的影响。当然，你可以说，实际上这只不过是一种历史模式的延续，因为实际上没有人——我的意思是，在宏观层面上，当 2014 年俄罗斯吞并克里米亚时，当 2008 年俄罗斯对格鲁吉亚发动战争时，曾有过一点小小的骚动。同样，西方几乎没有什么大惊小怪。甚至追溯到——所以回到亚当·柯蒂斯的那个纪录片，它的最后几集，说实话，简直惨绝人寰，讲的是车臣战争。那是一场难以置信的残酷战事，首府格罗兹尼被彻底摧毁。而西方的人们实际上在说：“好吧，我们不在乎。你知道，这是俄罗斯的内部事务。”
We'll just leave the Chechens to their fate. They just have to suck it up, basically. So had Putin taken Kyiv, had Zelensky fled, had Ukraine, let's say, been partitioned, then I think that would have i mean putin would just have said well this is just great this is more and you may well have started eyeing the baltic states do you think or do you think native membership would have well isn't one lesson i mean listen we're getting into politics here and i know our listeners will have some of our listeners
“我们还是让车臣人自生自灭吧。他们只能自己忍着，基本上就是这样。”所以，如果普京占领了基辅，如果泽连斯基逃跑了，如果乌克兰——比方说——被瓜分了，那么我认为那将——我的意思是，普京会直接说：“好吧，这太棒了，这还不够。”你可能早就开始盯上波罗的海国家了，你觉得呢？还是你觉得北约成员国身份会——难道不是一个教训吗？——听着，我们现在正涉足政治，我知道我们的听众中有些人
will have very strong views so i'm not intending to to just lecture them and pretend my own personal opinion is the gospel truth. But my own view is that NATO membership is clearly worth something. Yeah. Because if you are Latvia or Estonia, countries with a very large Russian minority. And Finland and Sweden, who've both joined. Have just both joined. So if you are Latvia or Estonia with a large Russian-speaking population, you know, maybe 30, 40% of the population, you would say, my goodness,
会有非常强烈的观点，所以我并不打算对他们说教，也不打算假装我自己的个人意见就是金科玉律。但我个人的看法是，北约成员国身份显然是有价值的。是的。因为如果你是拉脱维亚或爱沙尼亚，这些拥有大量俄罗斯少数族裔的国家。还有芬兰和瑞典，它们都加入了。刚刚都加入了。所以如果你是拉脱维亚或爱沙尼亚，拥有庞大的俄罗斯语人口——你知道，可能占人口的 30%、40%——你会说：“天哪，
NATO membership is what is actually guaranteeing our independence and our inviolability. And had it were not for NATO membership, we would undoubtedly be next on the menu. The other podcast we did, in addition to the episodes on Ukraine and the rise of Putin,
北约成员国身份才是真正保障我们独立和不可侵犯的东西。”如果没有北约成员国身份，我们无疑将是下一个菜单上的盘中餐。我们做的另一期播客，除了关于乌克兰和普京崛起的节目之外，
that has kind of haunted me ever since we did it is the one we did with Helen Thompson on oil we did two episodes on oil and this was I think it went out before the invasion and she was already in a very kind of baneful mood about the whole thing and she was talking of the risk of basic I mean she put Europe's dilemma in a really fascinating historical context that essentially ever since the coal-based economy came to be replaced by the oil-based economy europe's been stuck because it doesn't have the oil reserves that russia and the united states had and that in a sense that doomed the european colonial empires and therefore doomed the centrality of europe in the global geopolitical system.
自我们做完以来一直萦绕在我心头的，是我们和海伦·汤普森（Helen Thompson）一起录制的关于石油的那期节目。我们做了两期关于石油的节目，我想这期节目是在入侵发生之前播出的，当时她就已经对整个局势抱有一种非常糟糕的心情。她谈到了基本危机的风险——我的意思是，她把欧洲的困境置于一个真正引人入胜的历史背景中：本质上，自从以煤炭为主导的经济被以石油为主导的经济取代以来，欧洲就一直陷入困境，因为它没有俄罗斯和美国拥有的那种石油储量，从某种意义上说，这就注定了欧洲殖民帝国的命运，从而也注定了欧洲在全球地缘政治体系中的核心地位。
And it does seem that the invasion of Ukraine has kind of turbocharged the threat of deindustrialization that has always stalled Europe, I think. Yeah, I think that's true. I think it's a little bit like we did an episode, didn't we, just over a year ago about 1973 and the oil weapon. So it feels a little bit like 1973 in that regard. So what happened in 1973 with the oil crisis was that it laid bare what experts and insiders had already known, of course, which was the West's complete dependence on imported energy, on Middle Eastern oil. But that included the United States. And now the United States is not dependent.
而且看起来，对乌克兰的入侵确实给去工业化的威胁按下了加速键，而这种威胁一直困扰着欧洲，我认为。是的，我认为确实如此。我觉得这有点像我们做过的一期节目——就在一年多以前，关于 1973 年和石油武器。所以在这一点上，它感觉有点像 1973 年。因此，1973 年石油危机发生时，它赤裸裸地暴露了专家和业内人士早已心知肚明的事实，那就是西方对进口能源、对中东石油的彻底依赖。但这其中也包括美国。而现在，美国已经不再依赖了。
It's exporting its gas. it's fracking away you know it can impose sanctions on russia with a fraction of the damage that it's doing to europe to the european union and to to britain so helen thompson's argument is is that in the long run you'll see this great divergence or you know there's a serious possibility of a great divergence between europe and the united states both economically and politically because of our our energy dependence i suppose the counter argument would be that nobody would have anticipated before this year just how resilient nato the western alliance would be in the face of that's looking at it half full isn't it yeah i'm a very half full person tom you're half empty and of course um one rosy thing and i know how you love optimism don't you dominic i'm very optimistic and you love a bit of isn't it? Yeah. I'm a very half full person, Tom. You're half empty. And of course, one rosy thing,
它在出口天然气，它在搞水力压裂，你知道的，它对俄罗斯施加制裁所带来的损失，只占它对欧洲、对欧盟、对英国造成的破坏的一小部分。所以海伦·汤普森的论点是，从长远来看，你会看到这种巨大的分化，或者说，欧洲和美国之间出现严重分化的可能性很大，无论是在经济上还是政治上，因为我们的能源依赖。我想反驳的观点会是，在今年之前，没有人能预料到北约和西方联盟在面对——这算是看到半满的一面，对吧？是的，我是一个非常乐观的人，汤姆，你是悲观主义者。当然，有一件美好的事情——我知道你有多喜欢乐观主义，对吧，多米尼克？我非常乐观。你喜欢一点科学。我确实喜欢。冷聚变的前景，似乎已经离我们更近了一点，
and I know how you love optimism, don't you, Dominic? I'm very optimistic. And you love a bit of science. I do. The prospect of cold fusion, which seems to have come a little bit closer,
多年来、几十年来，这一直是能源领域的圣杯。因为我记得有一些英国科学家在 90 年代宣布他们做到了，每个人都兴奋得要命，但他们无法重复这个实验。但这次看起来确实更有希望了。人们正在谈论它在大约十年内投入商业运营。
which has been the energy holy grail for years, for decades. Because I think there were some British scientists who announced that they'd done it in the 90s and everyone went terribly excited and they couldn't reproduce it. But this does look as if it might be a bit rosier. And people are talking about it coming online in about a decade.
但今年另一项可能具有极其重要历史意义、并引起广泛关注的技术创新，实际上受到了我们《历史其余部分》俱乐部成员的大量关注，那就是人工智能（AI）。所以在过去几周里，发布了这款新的人工智能。是的，因为其中一位俱乐部成员
But another technological innovation of the year that may be historically very important that has got lots of attention, has actually got a lot of attention from our Restless History Club members, is AI. So there's been the launch in the last couple of weeks of this new AI. Yes, because one of the club members
让人工智能机器人模仿多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）的风格，写了一篇《每日邮报》（Daily Mail）专栏文章，赞扬阿根廷在世界杯上的表现。嗯，我见过，我收到了好几篇这样的文章，所以我昨天也发了一篇。读起来非常逼真。如果我是你，我会为你的未来就业感到非常担忧，因为《每日邮报》为什么还要付钱雇你来写这些东西，当他们可以雇佣一个机器人时？我来告诉你为什么，因为这个机器人不够具有论辩性。因为我收到了俱乐部成员发来的好几篇这样的东西，
got the AI bot to write a Daily Mail column in praise of Argentina's behaviour in the World Cup in the style of Dominic Sambro. Well, I've seen, I've been sent quite a few of these, so I sent one yesterday. It read very convincingly. And if I were you, i'd be very worried for your future employment because why would the daily mail pay you to come out with this stuff when they can employ a bot i'll tell you why because the bot is not polemical enough because i've been sent a few of these by our club members
所以我发过一篇，里面要求机器人写一篇我的专栏文章，抱怨“觉醒卫士”（woke warriors）废除了迦太基人献祭儿童的习俗。我指出，人工智能在很大程度上是一个“一方面，另一方面”的矛盾体，不是吗？当然，
so i sent one where the bot was asked to write a one of my columns complaining that woke warriors had abolished the carthaginian practice of child sacrifice. And I pointed out that the, the AI, the AI is very much on the one hand, on the other hand, is it? And of course,
在写专栏时，你永远只能站在“一方面”。对吧。所以你的工作目前还是安全的。还有很多东西要学。是的。读起来太像 A-Level（英国高中高级程度考试）的论文了。
in column writing, you can only ever really have one hand on. Yeah. Okay. So your job is safe for now. There's a lot to learn. Yeah. It reads too much like an A-level essay.
非常平衡。罗列了一堆因素。好吧。但这并不是公众想看的内容。好吧，人类社会还有希望。带着这个轻松愉快的心情，我们去休息一下。等我们回来，好吧，这将是今年倒数第二、倒数第一的播客半场。我们到时见。
Very balanced. A list of factors. Okay. But that's not what the public want to read. Okay, so there's hope for the human race yet. And on that cheery note, we'll go for a break. And when we come back, well, it'll be the very, very last podcast half of the year. We'll see you then.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，我们正在以一种天马行空的风格回顾 2022 年发生的事件。我们应该提醒听众，我们是在和亨利·杰弗里斯录完那期关于酒历史的节目之后才录制这个的，他带了一些波特酒来。他确实带了，他给了我们大约三杯。如果你——是的，如果你听到我们周围有人声鼎沸的声音，那大概是狂欢吧，对吧？人们在享用他们的圣诞午餐，一个个喝得酩酊大醉，从贝瑞兄弟和布拉德韦尔的各个地方被撤出……我们就是这样。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history we are looking back at the events of 2022 in a in a sort of rambling style well we've which we we should remind listeners that we're doing this after the episode we did with henry jeffries on the history of booze and he brought along some port he did he's given us about three glasses and if you yeah if you've heard people around us that's kind of revelous isn't it people having their christmas lunches departing very well oiled um from being decanted by from various places at berry brothers and bradwell we are so tom i'll tell you what a lot of people in britain will remember the year for without any question that, that's the death of Her Late Majesty, Elizabeth II. Well, there's been a lot of royal news.
汤姆，我告诉你英国许多人毫无疑问会铭记这一年的是什么，那就是已故女王伊丽莎白二世的逝世。嗯，有很多关于王室的新闻。
Yes. They're not going to remember it for Harry and Meghan, let's be honest. Well, they might. I mean, history books are always interested in badly behaving younger sons, aren't they? They are. There's a tension between the elder and younger son. Ludicrous self-serving misbehavior yeah has never failed to interest you know an earlier generation of young son would go off and side with
是的。他们可不会为了哈里和梅根记住这一年，老实说。嗯，他们也许会。我的意思是，历史书总是对行为不端的年幼儿子感兴趣，不是吗？它们确实感兴趣。长子和幼子之间存在着一种紧张关系。荒谬的、自私自利的糟糕行为——从未停止过吸引——你知道的，早期的一代幼子会去投靠
the king of france and try and annex gascony yeah um and now they go off to california and make self-pitying videos to be fair he wants to avoid publicity tom he does yes he does so the yeah so the death of the queen i'm sure that that will be used by historians as a bookend oh absolutely very very convenient isn't it yeah i mean i remember we discussed this in our episode on the queen and we said it kind of depends what happens you know in the next few years because obviously queen victoria's death coincided pretty much with the end of the 19th century and then the first world war came along. And I suppose if terrible things happen.
法国国王并试图吞并加斯科尼。是的，而现在他们去加州制作自我怜悯的视频。公平地说，他是为了避免公众关注，汤姆。他确实是，是的，他确实是。所以，女王的去世——我确信历史学家会把它用作一个完美的书挡。哦，绝对会，非常、非常方便，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，我记得我们在关于女王的那期节目中讨论过这一点，我们说这在某种程度上取决于接下来几年会发生什么，因为显而易见，维多利亚女王的去世几乎与 19世纪的结束不谋而合，然后第一次世界大战就爆发了。我想如果可怕的事情发生了。
Then it'll be the perfect literary device. Yes, it really will. Exactly. I mean, I think for me, what was striking about it, looking back, is there was always part of me that feared, in my sort of John Bullish way, that when the Queen died, people wouldn't react. You know, people wouldn't react you know people wouldn't care they'd be much less you know moved by it than i thought they should be and i was actually really surprised how moved people were and how rapidly every pretty much every single institution in the
那么这将是完美的文学装置。是的，确实如此。完全是这样。我的意思是，对我而言，回想起来最引人注目的是，我内心深处总有一部分——以我那种约翰·牛顿式（John Bullish）的性格——担心当女王去世时，人们不会有太大反应。你知道的，人们不会做出反应，你知道的，人们不会在乎，他们受到的触动会远比我以为的应该受到的要少。而实际上我非常惊讶，人们是如此感动，而且这片土地上的几乎每一个机构都以惊人的速度，
land rushed to put on the kind of the garb of mourning and the sort of the the almost instinctiveness with which a huge proportion of the public in britain embraced the idea of mourning the queen of you know that this was an important moment all of this kind of thing i mean there were of course there were and still are republicans or people who don't, but there are fewer of them than I thought there would be. You got cross with me for using the word weird to describe it. I'm still cross about that, Tom. I can't believe you'd bring it up. Well, I'm going to justify it because weird in the old English sense of things that are too strange to be contained within the kind of diurnal rhythms of everyday life.
争先恐后地穿上哀悼的外衣，英国公众中的绝大多数人，几乎是出于一种本能，拥抱了悼念女王的想法，认为这是一个重要的时刻，诸如此类。我的意思是，当然曾经有、现在也仍然有共和主义者或不赞成的人，但他们的数量比我想象的要少。你因为我用“诡异”（weird）这个词来形容它而生我的气。我还在为那件事生你的气，汤姆。我真不敢相信你把它提出来。好吧，我要为之辩解，因为“诡异”在古英语的意义上，是指那些过于奇怪，以至于无法被容纳在日常生活日复一日的节奏之中的事物。
Like Liz Truss. Well, exactly like Liz Truss. So she got put on, I mean, yeah, we'll come to her in a minute. But the sense that the British state is really quite odd, you know, it hasn't been kind of pulled down completely and kind of start again from scratch. So I've just been actually been writing a feature on king edgar in the 10th century right who and saint dunstan uh the archbishop canterbury who was famous for um recognizing the devil when
就像莉兹·特拉斯（Liz Truss）。嗯，完全就像莉兹·特拉斯。所以她被推上台——我的意思是，是的，我们一会儿会谈到她。但那种英国国家体制其实非常古怪的感觉，你知道，它并没有被彻底推倒然后从头再来。所以，我刚才其实一直在写一篇关于 10 世纪国王埃德加（King Edgar）的专栏文章，对吧？他还有圣邓斯坦（Saint Dunstan）——坎特伯雷大主教，他因……而闻名，
he came into his forge and grabbing the devil by his nose with a pair of tongs so this this dunstan what the devil was after up to no good he's the devil dominic the devil walks into your forge you don't have to say so dunstan was a blacksmith what's he doing in the forge he's a humble lad who grows up to you know fulfills every young lad's dream of becoming archbishop of canterbury and the devil came into his forge the devil came into his forge after a horseshoe or something i imagine he was up to no good dominic that is what the devil does okay i mean yeah i didn't expect to get here from okay but but this is this is the measure of how weird it all is so this saint dunstan who is attacking
当魔鬼走进他的铁匠铺时认出了魔鬼，并用一把火钳一把抓住了魔鬼的鼻子。所以这个邓斯坦，魔鬼来找他到底想干嘛？他是魔鬼，多米尼克，魔鬼走进你的铁匠铺，你还用问吗？所以邓斯坦是个铁匠，他在铁匠铺里干什么？他是一个卑微的少年，长大后实现了每一个年轻小伙子的梦想，成为了坎特伯雷大主教，然后魔鬼走进了他的铁匠铺。魔鬼为了一个马蹄铁什么的走进了他的铁匠铺，我猜他没安好心。多米尼克，魔鬼就是干这个的，好吧。好吧，我没想到我们会从这里扯到——好吧，但这就是这一切有多么诡异的尺度。所以这位圣邓斯坦，他用火钳攻击
the devil with a pair of tongs he's also the guy who devises the coronation order that is spoken when the person who i'd go to for when king edgar in the middle of the 10th century is crowned in bath amid the splendors of the roman. And that order of service for the coronation inspires the French order of service. It has influence on German and Italian royalty. But it's pretty much the basis for the coronation ritual that will be in Westminster Abbey when the king gets crowned next year. I'd like to think we'll do an episode about this, Tom. And I, what I felt about the mourning for the queen was people kind of getting in touch with a sense of the antiquity of things in this country,
魔鬼，他也是那个设计了加冕礼仪程的人，当 10 世纪中叶国王埃德加在罗马的辉煌中于巴斯加冕时，所宣读的就是这个仪程。而那个加冕礼拜仪程启发了法国的仪程。它对德国和意大利的王室产生了影响。但它基本上就是明年国王加冕时，威斯敏斯特大教堂内将进行的加冕仪式的基石。我想我们应该做一期关于这个的节目，汤姆。而我，我对悼念女王的感受是，人们以某种方式接触到了这个国家历史悠久的一种感觉，
an order that is so old that it does feature archbishops who go around attacking devils with tongs and quite enjoying it. I mean, people were, people were people were sad but i think they quite enjoyed being sad and they quite enjoyed the sense that everything had kind of stopped and for a while we weren't having to worry about list trusts or uh energy bills or whatever and we could all just queue up and it's quite a peculiar country in that it there's a large section of the british intelligentsia that has a very
一种如此古老的秩序，以至于它确实把那些四处用火钳攻击魔鬼并对此津津乐道的大主教们也包含在内。我的意思是，人们是——人们是——人们感到悲伤，但我认为他们其实挺享受这种悲伤的，他们也挺享受那种一切都仿佛停滞了的感觉，有一段时间我们不必担心莉兹·特拉斯或能源账单之类的事情，我们都可以去排队。这是一个非常奇特的国家，在英国知识分子当中，有一很大一部分人对他们自己的国旗以及……表现出一种非常
hostile attitude towards its own flag and displays of well this is the george orwell thing about rather stealing from the poor box rather stealing from the poor box exactly but of course we don't really have a national day we don't really have many national sort of overtly patriotic national rituals so actually this was very unusual a chance for people to go out into the streets to watch the bands to watch the the parades all of that sort of stuff we don't get many of those so i thought it was interesting that i mean she died in scotland yeah and again you have to wonder was that you know did she know that death was in near is that why she went to balmoral because that gave it a real charge and i think the scots
敌对的态度。好吧，这就是乔治·奥威尔（George Orwell）所说的那种“宁可偷穷人箱里的钱……”宁可偷穷人箱里的钱，完全没错。但当然，我们并没有真正的国庆日，我们也没有太多国家层面的、公开的爱国主义国家仪式。所以实际上这非常罕见，这是一个人们走上街头、观看乐队表演、观看游行之类活动的机会——我们没有太多这样的机会。所以我认为这很有趣，我的意思是，她在苏格兰去世——
were i mean they're much less they're much about the monarchy, I think, in general, than the English. But there was a sense that the rituals of the morning were very, you know, they were very Scottish, they were kind of played out in Edinburgh. And then, of course, they were played out in London. I think there was much more scepticism in Wales. And we talked, we touched on this in our episode that we did for the world cup on wales i mean we kind of made a joke of it but there is a kind of interesting ambivalence in prince william yeah who you know from early on had identified himself with english football team is now the prince of wales and when england were playing wales and you know he dead batted the question he did which team he was like she was not happy so you can under you i think you could understand why in Wales, perhaps they were less touched. But I think in both England and Scotland, there was a sense that people were in touch
同样的，你不得不怀疑，那是——她知道自己大限将至吗？这就是她去巴尔莫勒尔（Balmoral）的原因吗？因为这赋予了它真正的情感张力，而且我认为苏格兰人——我的意思是，他们对君主制的看法总体上没有英格兰人那么深。但有一种感觉是，哀悼的仪式非常——你知道的，非常苏格兰化，它们是在爱丁堡上演的。然后，当然，它们在伦敦上演。我认为在威尔士有更多的怀疑态度。我们谈过，我们在为世界杯制作的关于威尔士的节目中触及了这一点——我的意思是，我们拿它开玩笑，但威尔士亲王威廉身上有一种有趣的矛盾心理，
with an order that went back a very, very long way. And rather than feeling contemptuous of it, people quite enjoyed it. Yeah, I think that's right. I think as well, of course, you mentioned the fact that it was an escape from the political headlines. Right, so let's come to that.
你知道的，他从很早以前就把自己和英格兰足球队联系在一起，现在他是威尔士亲王，而当英格兰对阵威尔士时，你知道的，他非常敷衍地回答了那个问题——他支持哪支球队——他当时很不高兴。所以你可以理解，在威尔士，也许他们受到的触动较少。但我认为在英格兰和苏格兰，人们都有这样一种感觉：他们正在接触一种可以追溯到非常、非常久远过去的秩序。人们不仅没有对它感到轻蔑，反而相当享受它。是的，我想这是对的。我也认为，当然，你提到了这是一个逃离政治头条新闻的机会。好吧，让我们谈谈这个。
So this will also be remembered in Britain and perhaps around the world, because I think that the chaos of this year did win global embarrassment for Britain. I think internationally, there was a feeling that British government was basically stable, that it provided stable governance. People say that all the time. This is the kind of nonsense they say and the rest is politics i think that is anyone who says that just exhibits their complete ignorance go on then justify that i just said it so i'm no because you didn't say you didn't you didn't say that you thought it you said you thought people abroad said it and i think you're right that people let's say opinion op-ed writers at the New York Times says, what's happened to Britain?
所以这也将被英国人、也许还有全世界所铭记，因为我认为今年的混乱确实为英国赢得了全球性的尴尬。我认为在国际上，有一种感觉认为英国政府基本上是稳定的，它提供了稳定的治理。人们总是这么说。这都是他们——在《其余部分是政治》（The Rest Is Politics）里那种无稽之谈。我认为任何这么说的人都只是表现出他们的彻底无知。好啊，那你来证明这一点。我刚才随口一说，所以——不，因为你没说——你没说你这么认为，你说你认为国外的人这么认为。我觉得你是对的，那些人——比方说《纽约时报》的专栏作家们会说：“英国怎么了？”
And people always, Robert Harris-ish people, I like Robert Harris a lot, I'm not slagging him off. I think he said this in an interview with you in The Spectator, which is why I'm constantly... Yes, at now, so you can read that, folks. He came back from Germany and said, oh, people in Germany were saying, what's happened to Britain? They always organise everything so well. And I thought, what harold wilson 1975
人们总是——罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris）式的人物，我非常喜欢罗伯特·哈里斯，我不是在贬低他。我想他在《旁观者》（The Spectator）杂志对你的采访中说过这话，这就是为什么我一直在……是的，现在，所以大家可以读到。他从德国回来后说：“哦，德国的人们在说，‘英国怎么了？他们以前总是把一切都组织得那么好。’”我想，什么？哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）1975 年……
no you know margaret thatcher in 1980 won the most unpopular but it's the difference between um proportional representation and first past the post there's a general feeling if you win an election then you serve your term and that's why the the drama of mrs thatcher's deposition was was so was so brilliant was it didn't actually happen very often yeah or the 1920s. So in that 1922 podcast, we're talking about an enormous political turmoil. What is it?
不，你知道的，玛格丽特·撒切尔（Margaret Thatcher）在 1980 年赢得了——尽管是最不受欢迎的……但这是比例代表制和多数代表制（first past the post）之间的区别。普遍的看法是，如果你赢得了一场选举，那么你就完成你的任期，这就是为什么撒切尔夫人被罢免的戏剧性是——是如此精彩，因为它实际上并不经常发生。是的，或者 20 世纪 20 年代。所以在那个 1922 年的播客中，我们谈论的是巨大的政治动荡。那是什么？
Three elections in as many years. Governments rising and falling. By and large, post-war, I mean, you've written the books on it. You need to suck eggs here. But by and large,
三年内举行了三次大选。政府起起落落。大体上，战后——我的意思是，你写过关于它的书。你不需要在这里班门弄斧。但大体上，
if you win an election and you're the leader of a party, you lead it through to the next election. I mean, I know in the 70s it got slightly queer. So in the mid-50s, 55 to 57, you're free prime minister. But Mr. Satcher was prime minister for what?
如果你赢得了一场选举，而且你是一个政党的领袖，你就会领导它直到下一场选举。我知道在 70 年代情况变得有点诡异。所以，在 50 年代中期，从 55 年到 57 年，有三位首相。但撒切尔夫人担任首相有多久？
Ever. Yeah, 11 years. Kind of 11 years. Major was prime minister for seven years. Seven years, yeah. Blair was prime minister for 10 years. Brown was quite short, but Cameron had kind of five, six years, did he? Yeah.
永远。是的，11年。大约 11 年。梅杰（Major）担任了七年首相。七年，是的。布莱尔（Blair）担任了十年首相。布朗（Brown）的任期相当短，但卡梅伦（Cameron）大约有五年、六年，对吧？是的。
And then since then, it's just been kind of five six years did he yeah and then since then it's just been kind of getting shorter and shorter and shorter so may was i mean you know disastrous and chaotic johnson was disastrous and chaotic and then trust bet you know i mean she's the lady jane gray of she is poor i mean the thing about this trust is poor woman and the thing i feel sorry for her yeah well is this the peerage thing again? No, no, no. That's actually the thought, Tom. You're not going to get a peerage from this trust.
然后从那以后，它就变得越来越短、越来越短、越来越短。所以梅——我的意思是，你知道的，灾难性且混乱；约翰逊（Johnson）是灾难性和混乱的；然后特拉斯——拜托，你知道的——她就是简·格雷女士（Lady Jane Grey）——她是可怜的。我的意思是，关于莉兹·特拉斯，可怜的女人，而我为她感到难过的原因是——是的，这是贵族爵位的事吗？不，不，不。那其实是个想法，汤姆。你不会从莉兹·特拉斯那里得到贵族爵位的。
It's the thought of having to go and stand in the... The cenotaph. The cenotaph forever. But as you said, it's like a Greek... It's like Sisyphus pushing up his rock. Yeah. For the rest of her life, she'll be forced to go to the cenotaph. It's a terrible purgatorial punishment.
这是那种不得不去站在……阵亡将士纪念碑（The cenotaph）前的想法。永远站在阵亡将士纪念碑前。但正如你所说，这就像一个希腊神话——这就像西西弗斯（Sisyphus）推着他的巨石。是的。在她的余生里，她将被迫去参加阵亡将士纪念碑悼念仪式。这是一场可怕的、炼狱般的惩罚。
Quite soon. Probably in about eight years, people will start saying, who's that? She'll be like Lepidus, the guy who was left, you know, from the second triumvirate, who lingered on in a kind of phantasmal impotence for the rest of his life.
很快。大概在八年左右吧，人们会开始问：那是谁？她会像雷必达（Lepidus），就是那个从后三头同盟中被留下来的人，你知道的，他在余生中以一种虚幻的无能状态苟延残喘。
Yes. Yeah, because presumably she can't make an enormous amount of money from the speaking circuit. I mean, would you pay? I would have thought she'd be in huge demand for her advice on poor market opening up poor markets the economic and political stability um well who knows i don't know i think you see the the massive turmoil in prime ministers is really ultimately symptomatic of it's a couple of things
对。是的，因为据我推测，她无法从演讲巡回赛中赚取巨额资金。我的意思是，你会付钱吗？我本以为她在如何开辟贫困市场、经济和政治稳定性方面的咨询会非常抢手，嗯，谁知道呢，我不知道，我认为你看，首相们的巨大动荡最终实际上是……这是几件事的症状，
isn't it it's post-brexit it's definitely brexit it's brexit but it's also you know covid the horrendous economic challenges that we're facing so the system has really been buckling under the pressure how much worse are we doing than other countries but i don't think we are doing that i mean this is the this is the because i look at graphs yeah i don't really i don't really understand graphs this is the most absolutely tip-top i know but i know, I know. So there'll be somebody saying Britain's terrible. You know, whatever, we're awful. Vote Remain or Labour or whatever.
不是吗？这是脱欧之后的现象，绝对是脱欧，是脱欧，但这也是，你知道的，新冠疫情，我们正面临的可怕经济挑战，所以体制在压力下确实有些吃不消了。我们比其他国家的情况糟多少？但我认为我们的情况并没有那么糟，我的意思是，这就是……这就是因为我看图表，是的，我其实……我其实不太懂图表，这是绝对最顶尖的……我知道，但我知道，我知道。所以会有人说英国糟糕透顶。你知道的，管他呢，我们太糟糕了。投给留欧派或工党或者随便什么。
That's generally what they do say. Yeah, I know. And the graphs will show terrible. And then there'll be two or three people saying, actually, no, we're all fine. Everything's great. Liz Truss was brilliant. She was wrong. Here are some graphs proving it. Tom is proving that he spends far too much time on twitter but you but you must have come across the i'm very conscious of the graph because
这通常就是他们会说的。是的，我知道。而图表会显示出糟糕的结果。然后会有两三个人说，其实，不，我们都很好。一切都好。莉兹·特拉斯（Liz Truss）太棒了。她是错的。这里有一些图表可以证明这一点。汤姆在证明他花在推特上的时间太多了，但是……但是你一定遇到过……我很关注图表，因为……
i don't understand because if there are people out there who can to assure me to attempt to steer this podcast back towards a history podcast the trend for printing those graphs in history because you know they're very few you do get graphs i don't ignore very you know the trend for producing those really is a post-war thing and actually i would say that probably peaked in about the 70s and the 80s when the newspapers would print these every you know every week showing how we were falling behind and it would always print only those that showed britain at the bottom you know productivity worse than italy italy is always the benchmark still is actually people will say worse than italy as though it's i mean this is actually a perfectly functioning you know successful country
我不明白，因为如果有人能够向我保证——为了试图将这个播客重新引回历史播客的轨道——在历史中印刷这些图表的趋势，因为你知道，它们非常少，你确实能得到图表，我不会忽视……你知道，制作这些图表的趋势实际上是战后才有的事，而且实际上我会说，这大概在大约70年代和80年代达到了顶峰，当时报纸每周都会印刷这些图表，显示我们是如何落后的，而且它总是只印刷那些显示英国垫底的图表，你知道，生产力比意大利还差，意大利总是基准，实际上现在依然如此，人们会说比意大利还差，就好像它是……我的意思是，这实际上是一个运转完全正常、成功的国家。
well no now it's worse than poland is is it oh is italy worse than poland is worse than poland now we're yeah interesting now well of course yes i suppose because they've they've eastern europe has now been brought into the graph orbit but But I think, actually, when you look at a lot of these graphs, so people would say to me all the time, we did worse than anybody on COVID. We did worse than anybody on this. Well, we didn't in the end, did we? No, we did mid-table.
好吧，不，现在比波兰还差，是吗？哦，意大利比波兰差吗？比波兰差，现在我们……是的，有趣，现在……当然，是的，我想是因为他们……东欧现在已经被拉入了图表的轨道，但是我认为，实际上，当你查看许多这样的图表时，人们会一直对我说，我们在新冠疫情上的表现比任何人都要差。我们在这一方面的表现比任何人都要差。嗯，我们到头来并没有，不是吗？不，我们处于中游。
Mid-table. I think we were mid-table on actually quite a lot of things. We weren't wolves, but we were Villa. Well, you'll be wolves at the end of the season with our new manager, Mr Lopategi. Anyway, you can come back at the end of the season and see how that prediction has worked out. He's the one whose dad was a Basque stone thrower.
中游。我认为我们在相当多的事情上其实都处于中游。我们不是狼队（Wolves），但我们是维拉（Villa）。好吧，到了赛季末，随着我们的新教练洛佩特吉（Lopetegui）先生，你们就会成为狼队了。不管怎样，你可以在赛季末回来看看这个预测结果如何。他就是那个父亲是巴斯克掷石手的人。
Stone lifter. Basque stone lifter. So no, I don't think we actually have done quite as badly. I think it's become an annoying reflex. I just want us to do better than the French. Well, yeah, well... I don't really care about the others. Obviously, we shouldn't just mention the World Cup at all. Oh, i don't mind about that because uh you're so delighted about cricket no
搬石工。巴斯克搬石工。所以不，我不认为我们的表现实际上有那么糟糕。我认为这已经成了一种令人讨厌的本能反应。我只是希望我们能比法国人表现得更好。好吧，是的，好吧……我其实不太关心其他人。显然，我们根本不应该只提世界杯。哦，我不在乎这个，因为……呃，你对板球那么高兴，不是吗？
but also it's win-win for me england against france because um i have france in the sweep state there's been a lot of suspicions about unsound and unpatriotic behavior on this podcast and that is the proof no i think i mean we we did a stage show didn't we where we were comparing the the political turmoil in britain with the Year of the Four Emperors, a subject very close to your heart. Yes, the theme of a book that is coming out next year in July packs and will be available from all good bookshops. And one
但这也是我的双赢，英格兰对阵法国，因为……呃，我在抽奖中抽中了法国。在这个播客中，有很多关于不够健全和不够爱国行为的怀疑，这就是证据。不，我想，我的意思是，我们做过一个现场秀，不是吗？我们在那里把英国的政治动荡与四帝之年进行比较，这个主题与你心意相通。是的，明年七月即将出版的一本书的主题，它将精装上市，并可在所有优秀书店买到。其中
of the interesting things to talk about in that was that the Year of the Four Emperors, as you've said, it's not indicative of a wider sickness in the Roman political system. It turns out not to be. Although there are plenty of people at the time who worry that it is. It's pure faction fighting, isn't it?
一个有趣的话题是，正如你所说，四帝之年并不表明罗马政治系统存在更广泛的病态。事实证明并非如此。尽管当时有很多人担心它是。这纯粹是派系斗争，不是吗？
This feels like, you know, it's a struggle to deal with massive economic challenges, I would say. One of the things I also wonder is whether, I mean, one of the things to be said about the chaos in Britain over the past few years is that it's certainly been very democratic yeah there's been lots of votes have enabled people who otherwise wouldn't have a voice to
这感觉就像，你知道的，这是应对巨大经济挑战的一场斗争，我想说。我也想知道的一件事是，我的意思是，关于过去几年英国混乱局面的一个说法是，它无疑是非常民主的。是的，有很多投票让那些原本不会有发声机会的人能够
force referendums and to have their you know all that kind of thing and uh separate parts of the fabric of the state have been given votes on independence and all kinds of things like that over the past decade yeah and that's something that that seems very marked and perhaps we're just kind of airing problems that in other countries are, you know, being hidden behind the furniture. So if you were to control it. I don't know. I mean, I'm trying to cheer myself up. I'm not trying to cheer myself up.
推动全民公投，让他们在过去十年里能够，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，并且国家结构的各个不同部分都对独立以及过去十年中所有诸如此类的事情进行了投票。是的，这似乎非常明显，也许我们只是在宣泄一些在其他国家被藏在家具后面的问题。所以如果你要控制它的话。我不知道。我的意思是，我在试图让自己振作起来。我不是在试图让自己振作起来。
I know what other countries to go through what we've gone through. But, Tom, I think that's a completely legitimate thing to say, actually, because the obvious contrast that people make is with Germany. And people will say, well, the Germans, you know, they never have any of this issue. They just plod along. Angela Merkel, wasn't she great? And all this sort of stuff. But of course, a lot of the, we did a podcast after Merkel left, didn't we?
我知道其他国家经历了我们所经历的一切。但是，汤姆，我认为这绝对是一个合法的说法，事实上，因为人们做出的显着对比是德国。人们会说，嗯，德国人，你知道的，他们从来没有这种问题。他们只是默默前行。安格拉·默克尔（Angela Merkel），她不是挺伟大的吗？以及所有这类事情。但当然，很多……我们在默克尔离任后做过一个播客，不是吗？
Where we were looking at the sweep of German chancellors. I'm very proud that we nailed Schroeder then as a wrongman. We did, yeah. The Lord of the Rings, as they called him, because there was multiple, what did they call him? Audi man. Yeah, and then the Olympics.
我们在那里审视了德国总理的更迭。我非常自豪，我们当时把施罗德（Schroeder）钉在了错误的人的耻辱柱上。我们做到了，是的。他们称他为“指环王”，因为有多个……他们叫他什么来着？奥迪男。是的，然后是奥运会。
Because there was multiple marriages. And basically now he's married to Vladimir Putin's money, isn't he? Yes, he is. That's what he's married to now. And he's behaved really disgracefully. But actually, you know, now people look back at the Merkel tenure and they say, what a terrible mistake it was to jump into bed with Russia, to do the Nord Stream deal, to basically play the part of, I mean, this will sound very harsh to some listeners, so I don't really mean this to be as extreme as it sounds, but to play the part of kind of 1930s appeasers. I mean, that's some of
因为有多次婚姻。基本上现在他嫁给了弗拉基米尔·普京（Vladimir Putin）的钱，不是吗？是的，他是。这就是他现在嫁的对象。而且他的表现真的很不光彩。但实际上，你知道的，现在人们回首默克尔的任期时会说，与俄罗斯同床异梦、达成北溪协议、基本上扮演……我的意思是，这对某些听众来说可能听起来非常刺耳，所以我并不是真的想让它听起来那么极端，但扮演类似于20世纪30年代绥靖主义者的角色。我的意思是，这就是默克尔现在受到的一些
the criticism that Merkel gets now. She wasn't really appeasing though, was she? She was on the phone to Putin every week, once a week. Yeah not not not because she was appeasing him but because she wanted his gas i'm not sure is that better i mean no but it's different yeah it is different it's different you know it's you know appeasement is the is obviously the great bogey word that you you appease because you're frightened yeah i don't think she was frightened i think she just wanted you know she wanted the gas but i don't think appeasement appeasers were frightened either. I think they thought they could fix. I think they were frightened. I don't think they were frightened.
批评。她当时并不是真的在绥靖，对吧？她每周、每周一次给普京打电话。是的，不是……不是因为她在绥靖他，而是因为她想要他的天然气。我不确定这是否更好？我的意思是，不，但这是不同的，是的，它是不同的，它是不同的，你知道的，绥靖显然是一个巨大的可怕词汇，你进行绥靖是因为你害怕。是的，我不认为她害怕，我想她只是想要……你知道，她想要天然气，但我不认为绥靖……绥靖者也不害怕。我想他们认为他们可以解决。我想他们是害怕的。我不认为他们害怕。
Bomber will always get through. Yeah, but that's just a throwaway. I mean, attacking Stanley Baldwin is not something I welcome at the end of the year. I'm not. I'm citing him. At the end of the year podcast. Approvingly. All right.
轰炸机总能穿透防线。是的，但这只是一句随口的话。我的意思是，在年底攻击斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）并不是我所欢迎的事。我没有。我是在引用他。在年底的播客中。赞许地。好吧。
We've probably done enough political wittering, have we? Let's talk about some of our highlights of the year. So first of all, Tom, podcasting highlights. We have done done i sent you a text the other day didn't i and i said i think we've done in the last 12 months i work not including bonus episodes for our club members we've done an episode of the rest is history every two days that's amazing so that's something like just under yeah we did just over 150 sl. Massively slanted by the World Cup. So do you have any highlights you want to pick out for people who perhaps haven't listened to all that? I know it's hard to believe there are such people who haven't listened to everything we've put out this year.
我们大概已经聊够了政治闲扯了吧？让我们来谈谈今年的一些精彩集锦。首先，汤姆，播客的精彩集锦。我们已经做过……我前几天给你发了一条短信，不是吗？我说，我认为在过去的12个月里，我做过……不包括给俱乐部成员的额外节目，我们每两天制作一集《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History），这太惊人了，所以大概是不到……是的，我们制作了略多于150集。这很大程度上受到了世界杯的偏向。那么，对于那些可能没有听完全部内容的人，你有什么想挑选的精彩集锦吗？我知道很难相信会有这样的人，他们没有听完全部我们今年发布的节目。
If I chose two that would illustrate the sweep. sweep so one of the things that i really enjoy about doing the podcast is when we do subjects that turn out completely to surprise me and we are able to kind of think the issues through kind of live so unrehearsed yeah and i think the episode that most surprised me and and that in a way i was kind of most nervous about going out but also felt that we'd really got to grips with quite meaty issues was the episode we did on Senegal for the World Cup. So those who haven't heard the World Cup episodes, we took an aspect of the history of every country that was in the World Cup and we kind of divvied it up, didn't we? And there were some countries that obviously we knew less about than others. Costa Rica. Costa Rica being the prime example.
如果我选择两个能说明这种广度的节目。广度，那么我非常喜欢制作播客的一点是，当我们制作那些完全让我感到意外的主题时，我们能够现场思考这些问题，所以是未经排练的，是的。我认为最让我感到意外，而且在某种程度上我最感到紧张，但也觉得我们真正掌握了相当丰富实质内容的节目，是我们在世界杯期间关于塞内加尔的那集。所以对于那些没有听过世界杯节目的听众，我们选取了世界杯中每个国家历史的一个方面，然后我们把它们分配了，对吧？有些国家显然我们了解得比其他国家少。哥斯达黎加。哥斯达黎加就是一个典型的例子。
But Senegal I took because I had this image of the door of no return, the door through which 2 million Africans, it is said, were taken to America in slavery. And so I wanted to know more about that. And the process of discovering what that was, what it had been, the controversies around it, I found, you know, kind of really, really fascinating to discuss that and to research that. And then at the other end, I thought the episode on pigeons was an absolute triumph.
但我之所以选择塞内加尔，是因为我脑海里有这样一个画面：不归门，据说有200万非洲人通过这扇门被带到美洲沦为奴隶。所以我想更多地了解这一点。而探索那是什么、它曾经是什么、围绕它的争议的过程，我发现，你知道的，讨论和研究这个过程真的非常非常迷人。然后另一端，我认为关于鸽子的那一集绝对是一个巨大的成功。
So the origin of that was that I met, I sat next to Gordon Carrera, who is the BBC security correspondent at a carol service this time last year. He's absolutely lovely man. He said he listened to the podcast and he was dying to do an episode on pigeons because he'd written a book about the role played by pigeons in the First and Second World War. And I thought this was a great idea. All in favour of doing episodes on animals. And I'd love to do more. And I asked you and you did you poo poo it i guess anyway i persuaded you and we were kind of seeding it
它的起因是，去年这个时候在一次圣诞颂歌会上，我坐在BBC安全事务记者戈登·卡雷拉（Gordon Carrera）旁边。他是个绝对可爱的人。他说他听这个播客，非常渴望做一个关于鸽子的节目，因为他写过一本书，关于鸽子在第一次和第二次世界大战中所起的作用。我觉得这个主意太棒了。我完全赞成制作关于动物的节目。我很想做更多。我问了你，而你……我猜你泼了冷水？不管怎样，我游说服了你，我们当时在埋下伏笔，
and say telling people we're doing this episode people didn't believe it they thought you're making and in the event i thought the episode was fascinating it was fascinating he was a great guest so so i think those two would be the two that I would. And I would pick, so I'm going to pick two series that we did. I would pick, first of all, something that we were quite anxious about. It was the American Civil War. So we had a guest, Adam Smith, from the University of Oxford, an old crony of mine, who's an expert on the American Civil War.
并告诉人们我们在做这个节目，人们都不相信。他们以为你在瞎编。结果我发现这集节目太迷人了，它非常迷人，他是个很棒的嘉宾。所以……所以我想这两集会是我要选的。我会挑选，所以我打算挑选我们做过的两个系列。首先，我会挑选一件让我们相当紧张的事情。那就是美国内战。所以我们请了一位嘉宾，牛津大学的亚当·史密斯（Adam Smith），我的一个老朋友，他是美国内战的专家。
But it was that we were anxious about doing it as three Brits, for an audience that includes a lot of Americans. Yeah. And it seemed to go down pretty well. And I just thought it's such a fascinating subject. And Adam did it all in one afternoon, didn't he? I mean, he did about four hours. And he had to go to America the next day, didn't he?
但让我们紧张的是，我们三个英国人为一个包含许多美国人的听众群体来做这件事。是的。而且似乎反响相当不错。我只是觉得这是一个如此迷人的主题。亚当在一个下午就把这一切都讲完了，不是吗？我的意思是，他讲了大约四个小时。而且他第二天就要去美国了，不是吗？
He was really heroic. So I really enjoyed that. And the other one that just you and and i did because sometimes we do these sort of very detailed narratives to do with a single individual and it was young churchill i loved doing that i thought it was such so packed with incident and drama and he was more than gordon because i did enjoy general gordon was that this year i think it was it seems like a lifetime ago. Yeah. So those are two, those are companion series really, aren't they? Because they're about empire. Imperial daring do.
他真的很英勇。所以我真的很享受。另一个是你和我一起做的，因为有时我们会做这种围绕某个个人的非常详细的叙事，那就是年轻的丘吉尔。我很喜欢做那个，我觉得它充满了事件和戏剧性，而且他比戈登更……因为我真的很喜欢将军戈登，那是今年吗？我想是的。这感觉像是一个世纪前的事了。是的。所以这两个实际上是伴侣系列，不是吗？因为它们都关于帝国。帝国的英勇壮举。
Yeah. I mean, I kind of knew about Churchill to a degree, but I really didn't know much about Gordon. And so rather in the process of discovery. And the thing I loved about Gordon was that a figure who I had always seen as a slightly risible figure, because Lytton Strachey made him one of the eminent Victorians and kind of laughed at him for being sexually repressed and all this kind of stuff. And actually, when you situate him in the context of his age, I mean, he seemed to me a properly heroic figure. Yeah. In a way that I think today, we'd be, that kind of, that model of heroism would make us nervous.
是的。我的意思是，我对丘吉尔在某种程度上有所了解，但我真的对戈登知之甚少。所以与其说是在探索的过程中，不如说……我关于戈登最喜欢的一点是，他一直被我视为一个有点可笑的人物，因为利顿·斯特雷奇（Lytton Strachey）把他塑造成了维多利亚时代的杰出人物之一，并嘲笑他性压抑以及所有这些乱七八糟的事情。而实际上，当你把他放在他那个时代的背景下来看时，我的意思是，他依我看是一个真正英雄般的人物。是的。在某种程度上，我认为今天我们……那种英雄主义的模式会让我们感到不安。
And yeah, I agreed. I agree. And just before we go, Tom, a couple of other highlights from the year. So I know you're a great museum goer, walker, exhibition goer and so on. Is there anything that stands out for you? There was an absolutely brilliant exhibition that I think is still on at the british library um about alexander the great and it's less about alexander himself than about how alexander has been seen throughout time and across the world so it it you know there's there's a cartoon in which superman has to
是的，我同意。我同意。在结束之前，汤姆，今年还有一些其他的精彩集锦。我知道你是一个非常喜欢去博物馆、散步、看展览等等的人。有没有什么对你来说特别突出的？大英图书馆目前正在举办一个绝对精彩的展览，我认为现在还在展出，关于亚历山大大帝的，与其说是关于亚历山大本人，不如说是关于亚历山大在不同时代和世界各地是如何被看待的，所以它……你知道的，里面有一幅漫画，超人必须
rescue margaret thatcher who's been kidnapped by Alexander the Great which I thought was unexpected that is unexpected um and at the other extreme you know there are kind of medieval Chinese portrayals of him and all this kind of stuff I mean it's an incredible exhibition and it has so much material from so many different corners of the world uh so it's on in London the British Library I highly recommend that selection of books in the gift shop I understand well that helps as well yes it does it has books by both of us so my exhibition would be i think i mentioned this to our club members it's a museum just outside our house in denmark uh it's an absolutely wonderful museum with the most amazing um extremely sort of high-tech uh exhibitions and displays on the vikings and kind of medieval denmark but they had a particular exhibition on the roos on the Vikings and kind of medieval Denmark.
营救被亚历山大大帝绑架的玛格丽特·撒切尔（Margaret Thatcher），我觉得这真是意料之外。这确实意料之外……呃，另一个极端是，你知道的，有中世纪中国对他的描绘以及所有这类东西，我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的展览，它包含了来自世界各地那么多不同角落的大量展品……所以它在伦敦的大英图书馆展出，我强烈推荐礼品店里的那一套书，我明白……是的，这也很有帮助，是的，确实如此，它有我们两个人的书。所以我的展览会是……我想我向我们的俱乐部成员提过这个，这是我们位于丹麦家门外的一个博物馆……这是一个绝对美妙的博物馆，拥有最令人惊叹的、极其高科技的维京人和中世纪丹麦的展览和陈列，但他们有一个关于罗斯人、关于维京人的特别展览。
But they had a particular exhibition on the Rus, on the Vikings in the East. And we did a couple of episodes this year on the Vikings in the East. When I saw they had this, I thought, how can you do such a thing? Because there's actually not that much stuff. And it's such an apparently obscure and bizarre area of history. So the foundation of Kiev and the foundations of Russia and Ukraine and all this.
但他们有一个关于罗斯人、关于东方维京人的特别展览。我们今年做了几期关于东方维京人的节目。当我看到他们有这个时，我想，你怎么能做这样的事情？因为实际上并没有那么多东西。而且这是一个表面上看起来如此晦涩和诡异的历史领域。所以基辅的建立、俄罗斯和乌克兰的建立以及所有这些。
St. Olga, a great favourite of yours, Tom, burning the Derevlians alive and so on. And they did it brilliantly. It was incredibly interesting. They basically recreated the whole route and the sort of log canoes that they would have had going down the rivers, down the Dnieper and down the Volga. And then as you went through the rooms, you basically ended up in Constantinople and then in Baghdad. So it was brilliantly done.
圣奥尔加（St. Olga），你的超级最爱，汤姆，把德雷夫利安人（Derevlians）活活烧死等等。他们做得太棒了。这非常有趣。他们基本上重现了整条路线以及他们顺流而下穿过河流、顺着第聂伯河和伏尔加河而下时会使用的那种独木舟。然后当你穿过展厅时，你基本上就来到了君士坦丁堡，然后是巴格达。所以这做得太棒了。
I think that's an exhibition I shall remember to my dying day. The Scandinavians do really good museums. They do. So I went to Copenhagen and saw they've redone the National Museum. And the Viking display there is really superb. Yeah. Really, really superb. I think one reason they do them actually is because what was very obvious to me from Aarhus is that they just don't have the anguish that has entered into the sort of museum, the curatorial world in Britain.
我想这将是我至死难忘的一个展览。斯堪的纳维亚人真的很擅长办博物馆。他们确实很擅长。所以我去了哥本那根，看到他们重修了国家博物馆。那里的维京人展品真的很棒。是的。真的，真的非常棒。我想他们之所以能做好这一点的一个原因，实际上是因为从奥尔胡斯（Aarhus）的经历对我来说非常明显，那就是他们没有那种已经渗透到英国博物馆和策展界的痛苦。
So the captions were all comprehensible, Not so many abstract nouns. There wasn't the sort of hand-wringing and apology and all that sort of stuff that we are now so familiar with. So it was sort of the Vikings took slaves, the Vikings behaved very violently. Well, I felt that they could have been a bit more apologetic because there was an awful lot of English gold and silver there. So I did think that
所以说明文字都很易懂，抽象名词没那么多。没有那种我们现在司空见惯的捶胸顿足和道歉之类的东西。所以这更像是：维京人抢夺奴隶，维京人表现得非常暴力。好吧，我觉得他们本可以表现得更有歉意一点，因为那里有大量的英国黄金和白银。所以我的确觉得
a little bit of apology in fact contemplates ending it. Did you suffer harm, Tom? I did. I did you suffer harm i did i did yes i did oh that's very sad so i would love to go and see that that one and i recommend the um that the national museum in copenhagen and any any books stand out i know you read a brilliant book about the vikings this year didn't you uh children's book well dominic i'm not yeah i mean basic so basically i've i've been working so hard, Dominic, so hard.
其实可以稍微道个歉，正考虑结束呢。你受到伤害了吗，汤姆？我受了。你受伤害了吗？我受了，我受了，是的，我受了。哦，那太令人难过了。所以我很想去看看那个，我推荐哥本那根国家博物馆，还有什么书很突出吗？我知道你今年读了一本关于维京人的好书，对吧？呃，儿童书？好吧，多米尼克，我不是……是的，我的意思是，基本上……基本上我一直在拼命工作，多米尼克，拼命地工作。
I haven't really had time to read anything that wasn't about the Romans or to do with, um, the rest of history, the rest of history. And there've been some great books that that has enabled me to read. So yeah, Andrew Wolfe's book on, uh,
我真的没有时间阅读任何不是关于罗马人或与……《历史的剩余》、《历史的剩余》无关的东西。而这也让我得以阅读了一些好书。所以，是的，安德鲁·沃尔夫（Andrew Wolfe）关于……的书
the romantics. Yes. Um, Edward Shawcross book on, uh, that was a great, I'm sure there are others that, that I could could uh i could
浪漫主义者。是的。呃，爱德华·肖克罗斯（Edward Shawcross）关于……的那本书，那是本好书，我确信还有其他我可以……我可以
pluck uh and of course fury of the northman uh by yourself fear the vikings the vikings it's such it's so memorable and i should say that we just we had a cut just before this and dominic told me to say that so i still couldn't still go wrong it's shocking but it's brilliant it is it is brilliant full of stirring stuff about king alfred but dominic the real service you've done me this year yeah and i don't want you to think that i never listen to you and i never take your advice yeah so you made two book recommendations that i tom is reaching under the table i'm wondering what you're gonna get out the first we did an episode on uh the welsh and patagonia yeah we did and you mentioned uh malcolm price oh there it is last tango and aborist so these are a series of novels that cast aborist with as the equivalent
挑出来的书……当然还有你写的《北方人的愤怒》（Fury of the Northman），《恐惧维京人》，维京人，这太令人难忘了。我应该说，就在这之前我们剪辑过一次，多米尼克告诉我这么说，所以我还是不能……还是会出错，这太令人震惊了，但它太棒了，确实很棒，充满了关于阿尔弗雷德大王的振奋人心的内容。但是，多米尼克，你今年对我做的真正的服务，是的，我不希望你认为我从来不听你的话，从来不接受你的建议，是的。所以你推荐了两本书，汤姆正把手伸到桌子底下，我想知道你要拿什么出来。第一本是我们做过一期关于……威尔士和巴塔哥尼亚的节目，是的，我们做过，你提到了……马尔科姆·普莱斯（Malcolm Price），哦，在这呢，《阿伯ystwyth的最后一场探戈》（Last Tango in Aberystwyth）。所以这些是一系列小说，把阿伯ystwyth描绘成
of raymond chandler's los angeles and it's very surreal very funny and great detective stories so i've just gone and got the uh the that series. God, you're really addicted to them now. I have. And, Dominic, I've just gone and bought Patrick O'Brien's Master and Commander, this terrible book full of rope. The whole time I've been doing the rest of history, I've said I absolutely, you know, I tried it. I thought it's unreadable. And so many people have said, no, you've got to give it a go. And I've just blanked them because I felt that they were wrong but um we did a big series on trafalgar and nelson now that was i got massively into nelson and the royal navy and all that kind of stuff and so i did think i should give it another go and so um so i've got i've got i've got master and commander by patrick o'brien
雷蒙德·钱德勒（Raymond Chandler）笔下的洛杉矶的等同物，它非常超现实、非常有趣，是非常棒的侦探小说。所以我刚刚去拿了……那个系列。天哪，你现在真的对它们上瘾了。我确实是。而且，多米尼克，我刚刚去买帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brian）的《怒海争锋》（Master and Commander），这本可怕的全是绳子的书。自我做《历史的剩余》以来，我一直说我绝对……你知道的，我尝试过。我觉得它根本读不下去。有那么多人说，不，你必须试试。而我一直对他们置之不理，因为我觉得他们是错的。但是……呃，我们做了一个关于特拉法加和纳尔逊的大型系列，那次……我深深地迷上了纳尔逊和皇家海军以及所有这些乱七八糟的东西，所以我确实认为我应该再试一次，所以……所以我有……我有帕特里克·奥布莱恩的《怒海争锋》，
and i've got last tango in aberystwith by malcolm price which i'll probably have read by the time you're listening to this because I'm going to be reading them after Christmas. So thank you Dominic. Those are both your recommendations. You're very welcome. I do pay attention to what you say. And yourself? Because you read a lot because you review books. My book for the Sunday Times is a book called The Restless Republic by Anna Kay. And is she coming on the show? And she is coming on the show in a couple of months, I think.
还有马尔科姆·普莱斯的《阿伯ystwyth的最后一场探戈》，等你听到这里时我大概已经读完了，因为我打算在圣诞节后读它们。所以谢谢你，多米尼克。这两本都是你的推荐。不用谢。我的确很注意你说的话。那你呢？因为你读很多书，你为报纸写书评。我为《星期日泰晤士报》选的书是安娜·凯（Anna Kay）写的《不安的共和国》（The Restless Republic）。她会来节目吗？她过几个月就会来节目，我想。
It's all about England in the 1650s. So that's the era of the Cromwellian era. But the great thing about it, what I loved about it, is it was so attentive to ordinary life. So it's not just politics so cromwell is there
这本书讲的全是1650年代的英格兰。那是克伦威尔时代的时代。但最棒的地方，我最喜欢的地方是，它对普通人的生活非常关注。所以不仅仅是政治，克伦威尔在那里，
and there's lots of stuff about the major generals and all that kind of carry on but there are people telling each other funny stories and eating pies and falling out of windows yes exactly women call goody there's a there's a vicar who amuses his neighbors with tales of a character he's made up called mr prick there's all this kind of stuff which i think is brilliant because i've always wanted to know what life was like yeah and all of course so she's coming on the show and actually another guest who we've got coming on the show um in a couple of months wrote one of my other books the which is a book called tourists so she's lucy lethbridge and we did a series about. The book came out just as we were doing the research for it.
还有很多关于主要将领以及所有这些杂七杂八的事情，但也有人们互相讲滑稽的故事、吃馅饼、从窗户掉下去……是的，确实如此，女人们被称为古迪（goody）。有一个牧师用他编造的一个叫“普里克先生”（Mr. Prick）的角色的故事来逗乐他的邻居，有所有这些乱七八糟的东西，我觉得这太棒了，因为我一直想知道生活是什么样的。是的，当然……所以她要来节目，实际上我们请来的另一位嘉宾——我们在接下来的几个月里要请来的——写了我的另一本书，这本书叫做《游客》（Tourists）。她就是露西·莱思布里奇（Lucy Lethbridge），我们做过一个关于……这本书出版的时候，正好是我们做研究的时候。
The book came out about four days before we did the podcast. So basically the podcast just turned into us reading enormous chunks from the book out. But she was very sporting about it. And she's coming on to talk about the real Downton Abbey. Because about five or six years ago, she did a brilliant book called Servants about the colossal numbers of people
这本书在我们做播客前大约四天出版的。所以基本上播客就变成了我们大声朗读书中巨大篇幅的内容。但她对此非常大度。她要来谈谈真正的唐顿庄园（Downton Abbey）。因为大约五六年前，她写了一本名为《仆人》（Servants）的出色著作，讲述了从事家政服务的庞大人群。
who were in domestic service um and i'm sure that episode would be brilliant and actually that leads us to our last thing which is what we've got coming up in 2023 because we've got our tour we're doing a nation well a very short national tour in april um london the glittering heart of london's west end dominic the oldest theatre in the West End, I think. Is that right? Something like that, yeah. The oldest theatre that's always been a continuous theatre. So they've got Frozen on at the moment.
呃，我相信那一集会非常精彩。实际上，这把我们引向了最后一件事，那就是我们在2023年即将推出的内容，因为我们要举办巡演，我们将在4月份进行一次全国……呃，非常短的全国巡演……伦敦，伦敦西区闪耀的心脏，多米尼克，西区最古老的剧院，我想。是这样吗？差不多吧，是的。那是最古老的一直作为连续剧院运营的剧院。所以他们现在正在上演《冰雪奇缘》（Frozen）。
Soon Tom Holland. Yeah. Singing Marilyn. Yeah. So we've got the tour, but we've also got episodes coming up very soon in the new year. We have a slightly grim series, but an important series, about the rise of the Nazis. Before that, we've got Jonathan Friedland talking about
不久后是汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）。是的。扮演玛丽莲。是的。所以我们有巡演，但我们在新年里也很快会有新节目推出。我们有一个稍微有些阴暗但很重要的系列，关于纳粹的崛起。在此之前，我们有乔纳森·弗里德兰（Jonathan Friedland）谈论
The Man Who Escaped from Auschwitz, which we've already recorded and are amazing. Yes. We've got our long-awaited couple of episodes on Lady Jane Grey. We have indeed. So that will be coming in January. And then looking further forward, we're hoping to get into subjects
《从奥斯威辛逃出的男人》（The Man Who Escaped from Auschwitz），我们已经录制好了，非常惊艳。是的。我们有我们期待已久的关于简·格雷女士（Lady Jane Grey）的几期节目。我们确实有。所以那将在1月推出。然后展望更远的未来，我们希望涉足诸如
such as Columbus and his voyages and his place in history. The Ides of March. The Ides of March. Which will obviously be going out on the Ides of March. The Spanish conquest of Mexico. We are going to...
哥伦布及其航行以及他在历史上的地位。三月节。三月节。这显然将在三月节播出。西班牙对墨西哥的征服。我们将要……
Phoenicians. Yeah, we're doing the Phoenicians. We're doing Jezebel. Jezebel, yeah. Herodotus is coming. Yeah. The Profumo scandal is coming. The coronation.
腓尼基人。是的，我们在做腓尼基人。我们在做耶洗别（Jezebel）。耶洗别，是的。希罗多德（Herodotus）要来了。是的。普富莫丑闻（Profumo scandal）要来了。加冕礼。
Hundred Years' War. Hundred Years' War. The Cathars. And Ronald Reagan, a couple of episodes on Reagan. Was that a little hint of a Ronald Reagan? Just a little teaser there, folks. Just a little teaser. Gosh.
百年战争。百年战争。卡特派（Cathars）。还有罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan），关于里根的几期节目。那是对罗纳德·里根的一点暗示吗？只是一个小预告，各位。只是一个小预告。天哪。
You've been in Barry Brothers and Rudd too long, Tom. We can't start degenerating to Ronald Reagan impersonations now. We will be doing the American War of Independence. We will be doing East Germany. And we will be doing JFK, his life, his death, and the many theories surrounding his killer. So that's all yet to come in 2023. And we hope you'll join us.
汤姆，你在贝瑞兄弟与鲁德（Barry Brothers and Rudd）待得太久了。我们现在不能开始堕落到模仿罗纳德·里根了。我们将要做美国独立战争。我们将要做东德。我们还将做肯尼迪（JFK），他的生活、他的死以及围绕他凶手的众多理论。所以这些都是2023年即将推出的内容。我们希望你能加入我们。
If you enjoyed this, the rambling, unfocused, chaotic nature of this podcast. We actually do this every week in our bonus episodes for Members of the Restless History Club. And so I'm afraid a lot of the wangs, as we call them, named after the young lads who General Gordon looked after, they will have heard a lot of these anecdotes before. So I apologise to them. I think I've heard them more than once, Tom. Probably.
如果你喜欢这个，这个播客漫无边际、毫无重点、混乱的性质。我们实际上每周都会在《历史的剩余》俱乐部成员的额外节目中这样做。所以恐怕很多“wangs”（我们这样称呼它们，以戈登将军照顾的年轻男孩命名）会听过很多这些轶事。所以我向他们道歉。我想我已经听过不止一次了，汤姆。可能吧。
To be fair. Probably. But you can join up to the Rest Is History Club at restlesshistorypod.com and that will give you early access to all our live shows. You'll get the bonus episodes. You'll get loads of other treats. Incredible quality, isn't it? It's amazing quality.
公平地说。可能吧。但你可以在 restlesshistorypod.com 加入《历史的剩余》俱乐部，这将为你提供我们所有现场秀的提前访问权限。你将获得额外节目。你将获得大量其他福利。令人难以置信的质量，不是吗？质量惊人。
And incredible value. Very good value. Of course, if you didn't enjoy the rambling and focused nature of this, then you've lost nothing other than an hour of your time. And you can just carry on as a normal listener. Although, of course, we do hope that people will join the club, don't we? Because we're all about community. We're all about community.
而且物超所值。非常划算。当然，如果你不喜欢这种漫无边际、毫无重点的性质，那么除了浪费你一个小时的时间外，你没有任何损失。你可以作为一个普通的听众继续收听。不过，当然，我们确实希望人们能加入俱乐部，不是吗？因为我们全是为了社区。我们全是为了社区。
Yeah. So on that very, very public-spirited note, we should wish you all a very happy new year. And we look forward to... We won't be seeing you in 2023, but we look forward to you hearing from us. We might be seeing some of them in 2023. If they come to London or Edinburgh or Manchester. So we look forward to you hearing from us. We might be seeing some of them in 2023. If they come to London or Edinburgh or Manchester.
好吧，带着这种非常、非常有公共精神的语气，我们应该祝大家新年快乐。我们期待着……我们不会在2023年见到你们，但我们期待着你们听到我们的声音。我们可能会在2023年见到其中一些人。如果他们来伦敦、爱丁堡或曼彻斯特的话。所以我们期待着要么见到你们，要么你们静静地坐着听我们说话。全神贯注地。在新年晚些时候。所以祝大家新年快乐，再见。新年快乐。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。获取额外节目、提前访问、无广告收听，
So we look forward either to seeing you or to you sitting in silence listening to us. With rapt attention. Later in the new year. So a very happy new year to you all and goodbye. Happy new year. Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。